[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and the boys are back in
town with the second part of our
diabolical breakdown the entire series
is filled with easter eggs comic book
callbacks and a lot of things that
happen to the greater boy's law as i
mentioned in my first video amazon prime
sent this out for review in a different
order to what they released in so i
prepped my first video in advance based
off that however they switched it up for
the release so this video probably won't
be in the order you watch them for that
reason we're breaking down one plus one
equals two boyd in 3d bffs and lastly
john and son he if you want to watch the
other episodes they're in my part one
video and that'll be linked on screen
right about now anyway one plus one
equals two is the homeland origin story
we've all been dying to see and much
like all the episodes that preceded it
we opened with billy butch's dog tara
chewing a leg though he didn't eat any
soups per say in the comics there was a
cover where he could be seen chewing a
bloodied mask which this may be a
reference to however there's a lot of
body parts in this entry so it's
probably that instead the absolute mug
talking to myself there now from here we
could to stan edgar the ceo of war who
you'll know is being played by giancarlo
esposito in the main show he voices the
character and we also get work from
anthony starr aka homelander along with
elizabeth shue who reprises her role as
madeleine stillwell border unveiling him
to the world and they say that they
haven't been this excited by a superhero
since soldier boy not that soldier boy
no no soldier boy is basically a captain
america parody that will be played by
jensen ackles in season 3. in the comics
there were several versions of him
including one that actually slept with
homelander which will be interesting to
see if they do it in live action now he
explains his backstory and it's very
much the quintessential all-american one
you'd expect from an all-american hero
in season one episode six he took us on
a tour of his quote-unquote house and
very much gave us a superman-esque tale
about how he had a great home life with
his mother and father homelander called
his bedroom the baseball hall of fame
and this is the sport that he talks
about to make himself relatable to the
people he also mentions the whitehall
tigers which he had flag serve at his
home during that entry however as we
know from the series this is all just a
manufactured story to humanize him for
the masses and the truth is far more
horrifying we see the human
experimentation that was carried out on
him and this opening really shows you
why he's a complete sociopath now he
introduces black noir who takes the
spotlight away from homelander and he
completely overshadows him madeleine
says noir is a contingency plan for
homelander and in the comics we learn
that he's put in place to kill him if he
ever goes rogue unfortunately to talk
about this episode in depth we also have
to spoil one of the big twists in the
comics but i'll give you a heads up
before we jump into that now black noir
is clearly watching him and he stalks
the homelander throughout the episode
also we should probably drop the the
sounds better just batman and not the
bad sorry wrong video now at this point
we get homelanders first mission against
the clf who have taken over the cruise
chemical plant this very much feels like
a play on ace chemicals which is often
where batman inadvertently created his
worst enemy the joker the group have
taken the staff hostage because they're
poisoning the war to the point that
babies are born severely deformed but
being a corporation bought one to
protect them in any other superhero
story it would be about stopping the
evil company from ruining people's lives
and its clever subtext to subvert that
to the point where homelander is
basically brought in to protect
corporate interests desperate to get the
limelight homeland rushes in and in a
move that superman often does he wraps
metal bars around someone whereas this
is normally seen as a pacifist move that
won't hurt the person in real life it
means i just can't breathe he also heats
up a gun in another superman technique
but unlike the dc universe this just
makes it explode and blow the person's
hand off really really great ways to
actually deconstruct these classic
techniques and it shows how these kind
of things would actually operate in real
life he gets to the central room and
after trying to talk everyone down he
ends up disarming them this is a far cry
from what would happen down the line but
he would normally just eye laser them
without even aiming for the gun after
getting ptsd he ends up killing them
because they refuse to see him as a hero
helplander wipes out the entire group or
at least it seems that way and black
noir watches from afar the parent of
fighting with noir using several smug
bombs akin to batman and he tricks
homelander into killing someone by
pinning them to a flammable tank
homelander spams his eye lasers again
and this blows the entire facility apart
killing even the journalists outside
there's a soul survivor however noir
kills her and the two finally bury the
hatchet noir item a cover story and of
course the public bite now if you don't
want any of the comic spoilers then skip
to the next part of the video which will
be linked below we'd also appreciate the
thumbs up if you're enjoying the video
and don't forget to subscribe for more
boys content when season three drops you
gone good you schmuck didn't like that
guy anyway now in the comics it's
revealed that noir is actually a clone
of homelander the other series has
unmasked him and show that they're
different races i did want to give this
spoiler alert just in case they end up
doing something like that now in the
comics because noir looked like
homelander he could commit crime system
too the character dressed up in costume
and went out and brutally murdered
several people and he then took photos
of it nor then sent these images to
homelander and he believed that he'd
blacked out whilst this was happening as
he just couldn't remember it it slowly
sent him insane and it is possible that
noah killed those people in the episode
whilst homelander was having his ptsd
flashes being a clone he actually has
all the same powers as homelander does
unless he can move at super speed just a
theory but yeah something to bear in
mind for the show now the next episode
is boyd in 3d which features a man and
woman taking cream that alters their
appearance the woman ends up turning
into a cat person and it is possible
that this is the hero we saw at odie's
party in episode one now we joined boyd
a dog walker and in a bit of product
placement early on you can actually
catch an amazon delivery van as he gets
pulled across the street he also lives
in apartment 3d hence the title of the
episode now this is clearly a commentary
on social media filters and how we all
alter the way we appear to seem more
attractive this is shown early on when
cherry returns home after getting dumped
and she takes a photo to make it seem
like she's happy even though she's
completely devastated after applying to
be a test subject he rubs some cream on
his face called ambition which changes
his appearance one of the doctors is
kamal and johnny and this entry feels
like it's also playing on the feet of
clay batman animated series episode in
that matt hagen was severely disfigured
and he ended up rubbing specialized
cream into his face which changed his
appearance however he became hooked on
it and eventually ended up transforming
into clayface now much like how it
destroyed hagen the reveal at the end of
the show is that the entire thing is
somewhat of a fantasy and that he
actually died in the chair after
applying the cream this aesthetic has
been used in things like turtle recall
where the fantasy could potentially
start once he goes to the doctors and i
love the reveal in the dream he also
realizes that he wouldn't have been
happier either as the pair end up both
using the cream they become social media
sensations end up cheating and lose
their jobs at fort this is overseen by
ashley who you'll of course know from
the main series and she's just as brutal
as ever with nothing left the pair end
up fighting and they lose the last drop
of invasion which falls down the toilet
occurred to one man layer and they
rekindle their love after cherry brings
him a letter which reflects how he
wanted to give him one at the beginning
of the episode they realized they'd be
happier without the cream but it's too
late and he dies before any of it plays
out now next up we have bffs which is
written by aquafina the shang chi star
also voices the main character sky and
this is a highly anime inspired entry
about a sentient piece of poo skye is
forced to go with a drug dealer who gets
paranoid when he sees a picture of the
deep who pops up throughout most of the
episode we see signs for ocean land and
deep did a commercial for this in the
main series they crashed into aquapet
and skye ends up with some compound v in
her pocket and there's a lot of weed
talk and seth rogen actually voices the
dealer rogan is of course known for a
lot of his sweet comedies and he's been
very outspoken on how he smokes it every
day now i forgot to mention that seth
rogen and evan goldberg actually make an
appearance in laser baby stay out but
we're doing it yeah see guys i didn't
miss it i just forgot to mention it now
there's also a reference to the kyle
byne meme sky then creates a sunny and
boo and she forms a friendship with it
as it's basically an extension of her
she constantly does a count of 7 which
is a reference to the 7 and even has
some sweet corn in her cheek switch
lovely bit of attention to detail they
also have an et moment which they say
they're connected and as always it's all
connected now elsewhere the deep wants
the v as he thinks it'll convince the
seven to let him back into the group he
gets a great why to either dealer in a
death that could be riffing on the shark
one from license to kill there's also a
queen made dolan sky's room and
eventually vort offered to pay his
settlement after the deep attacks as
always it's super low and skye rescues
the pooh flushes her down the loo and
takes on the deep in the sioux
sewers now honestly skip that bit
honestly the powers of an anime finale
skye reveals her powers which is to
control turds and she unleashes an army
of them on the deep the episode ends
with her living with a brown gang in the
happiest moment ever [ __ ] happens and
that takes us into our final episode jon
and son he now this is one of the
standout entries of the run and it's
very much a metaphor for cancer loss and
acceptance the peace stars randall
dakima's jon and you might recognize
this actor as playing the keymaker in
the matrix trilogy now this is important
on a number of levels as both rogan and
goldberg say that they wanted to make
diabolical in the same vein as the
animatrix the anthology was completely
groundbreaking at the time and the entry
even has nods to the matrix like when we
see the cancer monster stopping bullets
written by andy sandberg we watches jon
steele's compound v from the lab before
taking it to his ill wife more try to
cover up what's happening and this
unleashes the monster which devours all
in its path as it's cancer it doesn't
hold back and though the couple try and
do whatever they can to stop it the
disease is relentless this devastates
john who we see from a photograph early
on has spent the majority of his life
with the woman he loves his bells are
past due he can't really live without
her and thus he makes a desperate
attempt to save her no matter what the
name sun he of course also sounds like
sunny and the entry ends with a
beautiful goodbye at the seven
headquarters john passes the mural for
the group which was also featured in the
show after the pair flee they end up
going to the woods where the cancer
leaves their body and it attacks all
that come close this is devastating to
the environment and much like cancer
it's completely ruthless we even catch
the inner workings of it which look like
cells and it seems absolutely
unstoppable fork clothes in and get
wiped out and though john and son he
could escape she convinces him to stay
behind even though it means that she
won't survive she leaves him with some
potting words that show how much he
cared about him and tackles the cancer
head-on which ends the episode it's
brilliant entry and like i said in my
first video i really loved the series i
know anime anthologies like this can be
a bit hit and miss but the season was
great and i had a hell of a lot of fun
with it now i'd absolutely love to hear
your thoughts so make sure you comment
below and let me know on screen right
now we have a link to our part one
breakdown and some other stuff that
we've covered in the week hopefully
you'll see over there but if not i hope
you enjoy the rest today you take care
of yourself and i'll see i'll see you in
season three yeah we're looking forward
to it take care peace